alors moi je pense que on n'a pas pris
la mesure de l'enjeu 2019
on risque d'avoir un parlement européen
eurosceptiques dans tous les pays
d'europe
le populisme monte en puissance donc le
sujet c'est de porter une vision
l'europe n'est pas parfaite mais elle
apporte des leviers par exemple sur les
sujets de migration qui préoccupe
beaucoup nos concitoyens nous sommes
organisés à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen c'est un outil puissant qui
méritent d'être complétées pas besoin de
traiter on peut travailler sur base
intergouvernementale dès lors qu'il ya
une volonté il ya d'ailleurs eu de très
grands progrès au cours des derniers
mois à l'égard de conair entre les pros
macro et écoutez c'est beaucoup trop
venus de décentrer c'est trop tôt pour
le dire ça c'est de la stratégie parlons
du fond comme elle quelque chose qui se
dessine c'est des choses qui font en
parlons du fond et des projets ce qui se
dessine clairement c'est qu'il y en a
qui trouvent que des défauts à l'europe
c'est monsieur mélenchon c'est monsieur
le pen et c'est laurent wauquiez dans
son ouvrage il ya il ya deux ans où il
voulait aller
il est très eurosceptique à nant dans
ses écrits même s'il a donné un
correctif
il a fait du et en même temps d'ailleurs
laurent viguier dans son récent article
dans le figaro
mais il est assez eurosceptique il ne
l'a pas toujours été
dans son passé alors que celle et
constructif nous sommes il n'a pas la
rater même été secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes qu'est-ce qui peut
tenir ce genre de discours aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu contradictoire abba
j'observe que dans ses meetings pour les
prémices d'une stratégie l'est c'est
haro sur l'europe sa mauvaise gestion
des frontières extérieures
par exemple et de la croissance et des
perspectives européennes